from a counter-terrorism point of view
it absolutely was worth it you know we
haven't had
al-qaeda inspiring or leading attacks in
britain in the levels
that they were across europe and indeed
9 11 and the united states so
from that alone do i think british lives
have been saved on the streets of
britain because of our deployment
yes absolutely and you know one of the
roles of a soldier is to go out
uh away from the homeland to protect the
homeland and from that point of view
i think our troops should be proud of
what they have achieved and at the same
time
the education that we have helped and be
enabled in women in afghanistan you
can't reverse that that there are now
educated young women in afghanistan
and no matter what comes next you know
education is is one way once you've got
your education
you can hopefully use that for the
better of the country and so we we can
bank those achievements
what comes next in the future that is of
course uh to be decided and we'll do our
bit as an international
a leader in the international community
to try and make sure that it doesn't go
into reverse
and six months from now what do you
predict will be the situation on the
ground in afghanistan
i'm not going to be in productions you
know that's for the job of the
intelligence services the foreign
foreign services around the world look i
think we have to take the taliban at
that word and we also
have to hope that all the training the
hundreds of thousands of afghans that
have been trained
by our military the u.s military and and
other european nations
uh it bears fruit and that they are able
to hold their own
and provide resilience to that society
and i mean
for you you're obviously you're you're
you've expressed
disappointment about the fact that we're
leaving in the way that we are
um are you confident that uh well
how worried are you that things are just
going to unravel i mean i know you're
you say you take the taliban at their
word but i mean they haven't really
proven themselves to be good to their
words thus far i don't think it's a
matter of worry i think i think the
simple reality is we have to prepare for
all
outcomes and there are a number of
outcomes that could come to pass
we want it to be the outcome of a shared
government a shared peace and to build
on some of the gains we've had
but of course if things don't go that
way we will be prepared
for whatever alternative we have to deal
with
what is the most likely outcome though
well i think let's see
you know i mean we are in a position now
where obviously you are reporting from
afghanistan you see what's happening in
parts of the ground but but remember you
know afghanistan is kabul is incredibly
important to the future of afghanistan
and
at the moment kabul is clearly under the
control of the afghan government and
and many people feel it will stay that
way so
let's see where we go and would you be
ready to put send forces back in
if the situation does deteriorate and
embassies are at risk
i think we're getting into lots of
hypothetical uh
scenarios but but the fundamentals is
britain will reserve
all sorts of uh rights to do what it
needs to do to protect british citizens
and diplomats and others
and asian aid agencies if necessary but
also you know we invest in those
capabilities to give me
and my prime minister the range of
options that he
can choose from should anything change
and have we learned to lessen
in the limitations of the ability to
nation build
i think what we have actually learned is
that it's really really important to
nation build and not just
deal with a military conflict as it is
and you know one of the challenges is
what is
short-term and long-term you know this
has been a 20-year deployment
is is it the case that actually
long-term is much longer than 20 years
that
that that in in today's world uh you
know 20 years actually turns out to be a
short-term
issue and and i think history will
suggest that long term is a lot longer
than 20 years
and therefore politically are we as a
country and and the western nations
prepared to really invest
in nation building or do we just visit
for a few years and then leave and
i think what what what history is
teaching us is that
a short visit doesn't usually fix a
problem and has the mission been a
success in your opinion that well i
think as i
said earlier the mission has been a
success from counter-terrorism you know
for nearly 15 years at least al-qaeda
have been
contained or defeated in in some parts
or certainly their leadership has been
uh removed and the consequence has been
safer streets from al-qaeda
um and you know that's good news for
british citizens now what happens in the
future
we all of course continue to monitor
al-qaeda we'll continue to make sure
where they are elsewhere in the world uh
we challenge them
but but that from a from that alone the
counter-terrorism operation that we went
into
uh afghanistan as part of the the
operation we went in to do what has been
successful and that has brought us many
many years of
peace from al-qaeda